koonta 24
lady to a limo feed the father
well hello related to Nadine if a tiny
Omar would I need the walkie on me I'm
gonna be lovin tomorrow but it'll be a
do-over her voice he'll be a very hard
that we do
what a meta-level better catch you
brothers and sisters today we're at
Kings 10 it's a Saturday don't exactly
know what date it is basically we're
here today obviously we'll do it down
with the brothers as usually in this
Saturday but today we try wanted to try
something different do a little social
experiment where we just wanted to see
basically we brought up a couple of
sisters but in touch with us and they
say they wanted to do this
Travel day so also we've been here a
couple of weeks ago as well and today as
well so basically what we do this to be
the sister gave normal 50 mils to try
the hijab to try the niqab to try to
avoid the Jill Bob and see how they feel
in it and get their feedback I'm going
to lot two weeks ago a sister wanna make
up and took Shahada and handle other
sisters help dirt and all these with
some really good Celerio as you know a
lot of people look at learning curve and
the Jew bar but something scary and when
you get a lot of people coming to see
why'd you just up like that why does
your woman dress I'm like that for
obviously we tried our best answer
misconception as much as possible but a
little bit of hate but a little bit is
what that was about the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him has moved from much
much worse and obviously we're here
we're trying it on the one to trade or
literally yeah but this isn't doing a
great job and a lot and a lot of people
have tried it on you getting feedback to
each other
but another ha
young
the real identity related to Nadine if
attorney my people were lucky I'm gonna
be loved and my buddy haha otherwise he
will be a very hard
w
our certified number
me and my buddy I do ha follow boys he
will be here very hard
that we go
and I feel really warm like it like
keeps over Hima
and I feel quite like religious even I'm
not like a part of your religion I've
never tried in the head covering it I
have wines at my friend's house because
like she got married to like a person on
that religion okay I feel humble and
modest and beautiful - how did you feel
about the heads got before you tried on
I don't know it's just a normal thing
that the different cultures were
when you tried it on how did you feel
after that fine normal I felt normal
but wasn't it Daisy Daisy okay before
you tried it on obviously you saw a lot
of Muslim woman walking around with it
what did you think of it I was in the
headlock of as you found it maybe a bit
weird
erm I didn't understand that why they
wore it is it okay we're in it now how
do you fool in it like um I don't know I
feel like I'm put like a religion is it
so you're just wearing the hijab right
now and it sees something what how you
feel as you where I'm going to stop you
it feels nice it's warm and nice and
warm it's its compass quite comfortable
you know so this is the Quran what the
Muslim holy book is and it's the Word of
God and joy too and give it out to us in
English originals in Arabic language we
spoke to a couple of women today
basically one of them was they were
interested in trying the hijab was like
an experience they never experienced
before and how to feel like to be a
Muslim woman I told him like do you want
to see the media since that we were
oppressed so I want you to try on and
see if you feel oppressed to know the
conversation leading to what is Islam
and one of them was atheists she
believed that she didn't believe in
anything and other one with Christian
the atheist one that she actually
understood the concept of God and Shetty
it made sense to her we had quite a few
girls actually trying on the hijab the
Jill verve the nabob all of them um
actually we had some people that didn't
want to take it off they really loved it
they felt comfortable I will say brung
along two of my friends and my friends
felt that whilst wearing the headscarf
they really enjoyed it and they didn't
even want to take it or I thought the
event today went really well
in regards to how people approach to us
because I'm the understanding with
people that don't where the table is
where enough AB means you're on your own
kind of thing like people don't people
find it hard to socialize with you and
stuff and I found when approaching
people they found it we really easy to
speak to us and I think they want to
know our perspective as well like they
were a bit surprised when we told him
that we actually wear the hijab because
of our own choice and not as the media
portrays it as oppressed and maybe a
husband or your brother or your father
forced you to Monica what I've met when
I were better care to brothers and
sisters today was an amazing day
obviously you heard what the sisters had
to say how they vent when what kind of
people they came across and it really
has been amazing to be honest and I had
two brothers yet they were involved with
me as well did you get any people like
comment and basically in a way with
misconceptions yeah people were really
like forceful with the way that they
came up with their ideas and they try to
indoctrinate but my handle I was a
really good conversation I didn't go
after you kind of made him understand
about the misconceptions they kind of
understand a bit oh I did tell them that
what they were saying and I explained it
and it was it was a really good exercise
for me actually to strengthen my Deen
and understand that I need to do more
research and that they and it's just
built a really good connection well
that's amazing that's amazing what about
you how did you come across anyone
that's a bit like vitam because we had
one guy who came and he's like oh you
guys don't show your face you are going
in a mad one not even talk to me just go
run off all right no I didn't come
across people like that but it was just
normal normal people that trying to come
to the come to the Dean yeah
learn about the Dean bar I've just had
some couple people here a couple of
people were saying yeah what is Islam
what does it teach who is prophet
muhammad sallallahu alayhi wasallam
teaching them how the bible says it in
their own Bible okay and they learn
I know it's good that's good so
regarding what the experiment the
sisters did giving was effective do you
think we should have more sisters
engaging with these kind of stuff yes
it's good to see sisters coming out
trying to give down to other Muslim
Alberta just the other sisters and women
non-muslim because it shows them why why
our moment do it cover up not because we
forced them that because they want to
just have modesty because of the Quran
and Sunnah tells them to yeah exactly
what about you do you think it was
effective to do what the sisters did
that you know we had a lot of non-muslim
females coming and they were really
interested yeah they wanted to try it on
yeah these non-muslims they were really
really AM open and it cleared a lot of
misconceptions like fertile I said
mashallah so it was a great great great
day yeah so our brothers and sisters
what we can say it was an amazing day
it's obviously when it comes from our
mouth or saying look how a woman are not
oppressed is different - we have
insistence come in and basically saying
you know what we are not oppressed we
were a cause of this and this cause it
makes it better for them for them to
understand so obviously that was
important and we have to do as much as
we can you know if if you want you can
do this in your own City obviously for
safety get your brothers or cousins
whoever's involved to be there with you
to keep an eye you know we tried our
best and I think really did I think we
did really well you know I'm not like a
lot of people liked it even if it didn't
take seriously that you know you never
know like two years down the line they
might think you know what let me see
what that religion was about I tried a
couple of years ago so it can have that
effect in their heart you never know I
was want Allah guide him in any way Judy
I'm trying to say you know they might
try the niqab and be like you know what
yeah I feel a bit safe in it you can I'm
trying to say something it was really
amazing
inshallah share this video with
non-muslim friends and you shall try to
do your own thing as well you know
that's about it from us may Allah's
mercy and blessings be upon you all
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah wa
barakatu